I want to talk to you about your
personal life if that's okay uh you can
tell me if it's not rather boring well
no it's not boring uh I've actually I've
actually encountered you several times
out in the world when you're on
different dates in the wild in the wild
know in restaurants you came over to my
house you brought a fellow over to my
house one night and uh and you're always
sort of asking me you you'll say C let's
go to the kitchen you'll be like what do
you think and um I'm just curious and
you're the one that goes go for it go
for it and then boom yeah I didn't say
well why are you asking me I'm a
terrible I don't know these things I
don't know who's a good guy and who's
not a good guy I'll fight them all if
they're not good to you thank you but is
it is it is it bumpy these days or is it
going smoothly the relationship
thing uh see the word tumble weeds comes
to mine oh nothing's happening right now
well you know you got to be in one town
right you got to be in one spot to
actually date somebody but I guess I've
had some I have somebody I kind of like
but in the past maybe couple years I've
had some interesting you know one guy um
we were watching we had been dating a
while and he said he'd like to um try on
my pajama bottoms he wait he asked you
he asked you if he could try on your
pajama bottoms yes sir I'm not a cop
interviewing you I feel like I'm back
back at the Boston airport yeah um yes
he wanted to try on my pants and I and I
said I am so hurt he said and my friend
was said was it because he wanted to
wear your pants I said no that he
thought he could fit him yeah well
that's just such a weird thing did he
was it like a kinky thing that he he
wanted to relax he said oh that's just
weird not judging anybody but I don't
want to date that you know what I mean
right right so these were like long
pajama bottoms that they were pink with
white polka dots from Victoria Secret oh
yeah no I I'm fine with wearing that
stuff under my suit I don't just I just
don't think let anyone know I'm
comfortable I feel comfortable we were
watching a TV show I guess he wanted to
get out of his tight jeans anyway that
ended okay uh any other bad like anyone
that's enough isn't it well no I was yes
I was this was a while back my dad um
had business in Puerto Rico so I decided
to go with him and I was laying on the
beach and I didn't realize that my then
boyfriend was going to surprise me now
we had just again just started dating
and I saw this man at the time he was 5
years older than me and I thought oh
he's so old now of course I think he's
young but he comes jogging well I didn't
know who it was this man comes jogging
on the beach just like you'd see in a
movie like almost slow motion in a
speedo and I was laying there and I
thought oh that man oh the poor woman
that has to get that and he got closer
and
closer and it was for
me just a slowmo to Speedo I just never
KN I don't know how you women feel about
Speedos no I've Been Told
I've been told not for me personally I
would never I'm I'm very covered all I
wear a 1920s bathing suit but and I got
a straw hat and I'm like we're going to
the beach yeah oh yeah but I would never
wear one a million years but I women
uniformally say like oh no I don't like
a speedo it's much you we think we
should right but he was heading toward
me and I was heading towards a away and
that was the end of that you know this
show this show tonight might help you
find a fella you know there might be
with your show I always get prison mail
when I get home
that's true it is
true you know what I'm going to do I get
a lot of prison mail did you know I do
meet people who say like hey man I love
you I watched you in prison for like 5
years then I got out I get those mail
from because of you thank you yeah
you're welcome I open it thank you and I
open it up I like dear Kristen you're so
pretty and talented I'm like oh I might
like I'm here in lenworth for five more
years and I think well D wait for me
were you innocent were you innocent or
guilty but I'm going to start saving
them and when I come back on the show
we'll read them together yes read read
the prison mail here I like to make
friends wherever they are uh me too me
too